on peut être pour ou contre mais la
techno cette musique qui utilisent
largement l'informatique dans sa
conception n'est plus considérée
aujourd'hui comme une simple bonne mais
comme un véritable mouvement de fond
comme le rock des années 50 60 des
industriels n'hésitent pas d'ailleurs à
investir beaucoup d'argent dans cette
musique née dans les années 1980 c'est
ainsi l'enquète de nicolas winckler et
pascal caron est intitulé ce soir les
enfants de la génération technique
berlin juillet 96 près d'un million de
jeunes décembre dans la rue ce qui les
unit d'abord une musique la techno
ensuite des valeurs tolérance
d'ouverture on n'est pas bien loin du
slogan peace and love pour ceux qui se
souviennent de woodstock
ces images doivent avoir un air de déjà
vu le phénomène est mondial
la déferlante techno déplace les films
comme ici au début du mois à paris lors
du mx move une sorte de salon de la
techno qui pendant trois jours était
archicomble une véritable culture techno
est en train de naître il veut se faire
entendre même si elle dérange d'écouter
toutes ces musiques là bon ben on en a
marre d'avoir des soirées annulé d'avoir
des festivals annulé d'avoir des gens
qui investissent pour faire avancer sa
musique là et qui se retrouvent qui se
retrouvent à la rue parce que
on leur a interdit on se croirait dans
une discothèque
on est en fait à pain riz dans l'une des
boutiques à la mode les grands groupes
de prêt-à-porter sont parmi les premiers
à avoir compris l'importance de ce
mouvement
tout simplement parce qu'il y avait de
l'argent à la clé la tendance est aux
couleurs vives
cette boutique de 1200 m² que dette
animant succès commercial
tout simplement parce qu'elle a su être
à l'écouté des jeunes il est tellement
pourri tout tout est décevant quoi la
bomba pour nous faire éclater cossure de
musique on arrive à s'évader se faire
son propre nom de la soie est ce que dit
vraiment rien ils disent que ça va pas
ça a pas duré longtemps
c'est la mode comme ça qui passe après
si ça finira mais musique des photos
s'ils pensent que c'est moi je pense ça
va durer pourquoi parce que tous les
gènes hla de coûts commencent à s'y
mettre
comment ça se met à la mode ça devient
un phénomène de masse je dirais que l'on
vit et elle est la force de cette
jeunesse est telle qu'on ne peut rien
arrêter la machine est partie en plus
rien n'arrête séances de studio
vous comprenez ici dès le premier coup
d'oeil que ce qui caractérise la techno
c'est d'abord l'utilisation maximale de
l'informatique un extraordinaire outil
qui offre des possibilités de création
sonore presque infinies mais surtout un
outil à la portée de tous un simple
ordinateur et vous voici à la tête d'un
orchestre synthétique des milliers de
jeunes sont aujourd'hui équipés ce sont
eux qui font la vie d'un mouvement
musical qui ne cesse d'inventer et de
tenter de nouvelles directions
[Musique]
on a tous la baisse progressivement pour
donner un ordre d'idée
maintenant on arrive dans la techno à
des ventes de plus de 100000 plus de
cent mille exemplaires sur des
compilations pas sur des albums sas et
c'est relativement nouveau nom c'est
relativement nouveau ce jeudi rexel
année 96 qui voit un début d'explosion
de la techno derrière cette porte
moyenne d'âge 25 ans ce sont les locaux
de radio fg la radio techno à paris
entre 80000 et 100000 auditeurs par jour
c'est plus que france culture france
musique un succès qui ne se dément pas
depuis bientôt six ans les français se
méfient un petit peu et la techno c'est
pas un coup c'est pas un coût de 3,4
producteurs musicaux qui ont fomenté ça
pour vendre quelques disques en l'espace
de 3 mois non set musical existe depuis
15 ans à peu près 10 15 ans elle est née
au tout début des années 80 il est 3
heures du matin c'est tout juste le
début de la bousculade aux portes de
l'elysée montmartre à paris
à l'intérieur 1200 personnes tous des
technophiles
pour eux la techno c'est plus qu'une
musique c'est aussi une façon de vivre
folie un peu comme le discours des 80 la
techno la musique qui en train de
révolutionner tout tout comme le
rock'n'roll la plus révolutionnaire
révolution qu elle révolutionnaire un
nouvel état d'esprit on a souvent fait
l'amalgamé entre la techno la drogue
tiens tiens c'est exactement le même
procès qui avait été fait en leur temps
aux rockeurs ou guéï et l'histoire se
répète donc diaboliser la techno c'est
sans doute déjà un combat du passé
[Musique]